bonsoir meriem vous avez suivi de près
cette affaire que peut-on retenir de ces
deux premières semaines de procès qui
doit endurer 3 normalement un oui eh
bien oui la deuxième semaine du procès
viennent de s'achever ces deux semaines
ont été marquées par la difficulté pour
les observateurs de suivre les audiences
et par des témoignages qui on peut le
dire ont marqué les esprits et à quelles
difficultés meriem se sont heurtés les
observateurs alors tout d'abord il y a
eu la difficulté pour certaines
organisations telles que reporters sans
frontières et amnesty international à
avoir accès à l'audience
seules deux personnes de rsf ont pu être
autorisés à suivre le procès mais après
seulement d'âpres négociations selon ray
des cas vincent qui est la directrice
des campagnes internationales de rsf qui
ajoute qu il a même fallu l'intervention
de l'ambassade d'allemagne à londres
pour exercer une pression pour qu'il
puisse avoir des déplace au procès alors
je dis il faut savoir que à l'intérieur
du tribunal du old bailey
très peu de personnes sont présentes
physiquement selon les informations que
nous avons pu recueillir il y a
seulement sur place la juge vanessa
béret barré d'air entourée de deux
greffiers deux avocats pour chaque
partie et une dizaine de personnes dans
le public et julian assange était-il
présent sur place oui il est présent sur
place du lan assange est placé dans un
box derrière une vitre au fond de la
salle d'audience sa compagne stella
maurice a raconté dans un tweet la
manière dont il est transporté de la
prison de belmarsh au tribunal qui se
trouve dans le centre de londres
je la cite chaque jour il est réveillé à
5 heures du matin menotté et placé dans
une des cellules de détention
déshabiller et radiographier il est
transporté durant une heure trente dans
ce qui ressemble à un cercueil verticale
dit elle dans une toute petite
camionnette et le box dans lequel il est
placé au fond du tribunal ne lui permet
pas d'avoir un accès correct à ses
avocats selon sa compagne joue les uns à
100 e pardon stella maurice
par ailleurs les journalistes qui
rendent compte des
des audiences en temps réel font état
que julian assange
quand il intervient pendant les
audiences parfois pour protester la juge
vanessa paré d'or le menace de l'exclure
du procès s'il recommence est ce que la
presse
elle est admise au tribunal en fait la
plupart des journalistes sont en
visioconférence d'ailleurs ils parlent
tous de problèmes techniques récurrents
notamment au niveau du son entraînant de
selon eux de grandes difficultés à
suivre les débats de nombreuses
interruptions de séance également
certains font état aussi de
l'impossibilité de se connecter parfois
du jour au lendemain pour pouvoir suivre
les audiences
meriem rappelez-nous quels sont les
accusations qui pèsent sur julian
assange alors l'accusation américaine
portant en grande partie sur
l'allégation selon laquelle les
révélations de wikileaks aurait mis en
danger des vies humaines celles ci il
s'agit de d'informateurs de des états
unis en irak et en afghanistan donc des
afghans et des irakiens dont les noms
aurait été divulgué par les fuites de
wikileaks à l'époque en 2010 mais de
nombreux témoignages ont remis en cause
cette accusation
les débats ont quand même pu avoir lieu
malgré les circonstances qui semble
complexe meriem est ce que vous avez
retenu des témoignages clés et
pouvez-vous nous dire lesquelles selon
vous oui plusieurs témoignages deux par
jour en général ce sont deux se sont
succédé à au tribunal parmi tous ces
témoignages ceux de jungle et de daniel
ellsberg ont particulièrement mal tu
remarqué les esprits lors de l'audience
de mercredi de mercredi 16 septembre
jungle c'est un journaliste allemand qui
avait participé aux publications massif
de wikileaks en 2010 à propos des
guerres d'irak et d'afghanistan il
travaillait à cette époque pour le
magazine der spiegel qui comme vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure fait
partie des cinq le grand média qui ont
participé au niveau international aux
révélations de wikileaks jungle s'assure
que julian assange a personnellement
veillé à ce que les noms des personnes
vulnérables ne soit jamais publié qu'il
était très inquiet à ce sujet il a
également rappelé à la cour qu'à travers
le new york times le département d'état
américain avait été consultée par
wikileaks et ses partenaires de l'époque
et qu'il avait émis des préconisations
suite à cette préconisation du lan
assange avait décidé de ne pas publier
environ 15 mille documents confidentiels
justement pour protéger les vies
humaines vulnérables le tribunal a
ensuite entendu daniel ellsberg ancien
analyste du pentagone danneels dernier
l'homme des pentagon papers valorise
donc c'était des révélations sur la
guerre du vietnam en 1971
ces révélations avaient défrayé la
chronique et avait remis en cause le
storytelling sur la guerre du vietnam
qui qui qui duraient déjà depuis presque
20 ans là bas
daniel que ellsberg est considéré comme
le premier des lanceurs d'alert il a
affirmé que wikileaks avait agi dans
l'intérêt du public
il a estimé en outre que le gouvernement
étasunien était je cite extrêmement
cynique en prétendant qu'ils se soucient
de ces personnes qui ont servi les
intérêts américains en irak et en
afghanistan
pour lui le mépris pour le moins les
moyen-orientaux a été démontré au cours
des 19 dernières années avec
l'expérience des états unis dans cette
région du monde
selon daniel ellsberg enfin assange ne
pourrait pas bénéficier d'un procès
équitable s'il était extradé aux
etats-unis c'est en tout cas ce qu'il a
affirmé à la juge vanessa barre et dira
merci beaucoup meriem pour toutes ces
explications meriem les rives et donc
sur les deux semaines du procès assange
un procès qui va encore se poursuivre
donc la semaine prochaine